Yo me encuentro en este momento en la
biblioteca Ponce de León en el condado
de panty es uno de los condados pues más
importantes porque es donde se agrupa la
mayor votación aquí en Georgia y donde
en elecciones pasadas pues ha definido
el control del senado y incluso de la
presidencia avanza avanza lentamente
porque ha habido mucha lluvia por la
mañana y esta lluvia precisamente pues
tiene en alerta los candidatos sobre
todo al candidato demócrata que sabe que
son los republicanos los que votan más
el día de la elección y son los
simpatizantes demócratas los que votan
más de forma anticipada de forma
anticipada ha habido una votación récord
1,8 millones de ciudadanos del estado de
Georgia han votado de forma anticipada
pero se espera que esa votación sea
mucho más grande hoy día de la elección
las urnas cierran a las siete de la
noche y las encuestas Aunque dan por
encima a worknock el candidato demócrata
Pues hay alerta porque precisamente hoy
el día de la votación muchos
republicanos salen a votar y ese margen
podría ser mucho más estrecho a la hora
del conteo bueno Cristóbal por qué ni
biden ni Trump se encuentran presentes
haciendo campañas allí en Georgia
según una lista es lo que dicen es que
estos dos políticos importantísimos
obviamente presidente y expresidente de
Estados Unidos pues polarizan mucho al
país tanto para los republicanos como
para los demócratas Ninguno de los
candidatos quiere estar en tarima con
ellos porque pues eh evitan que el
votante de Centro el votante
independiente termine votando por ellos
sobre todo en un estado como Georgia que
se consideraba rojo pero que en las
últimas elecciones pues ha Tornado
púrpura teniendo en cuenta que pues ha
sido yo ya el que terminó eligiendo a el
presidente Joe biden y que pues ha
votado demócrata en el senado entonces
pues es bastante relevante precisamente
que no estén los Donald Trump aquí pero
pues es para bien de los candidatos
Según dice analistas y para bien de los
votantes independientes que tendrán
hasta las siete de la noche para votar y
que ya Además está diciendo que este
voto sobre todo en este condado del
Condado de fonti podría demorarse
teniendo en cuenta el estrecho margen
que en la primera ronda le sacó